[Music]
I'm worried for you now because you are
picking on some pretty tough guys don't
you in are they I mean I'm picking on
big guys for sure but I think those
muscles are all show no go there's no
way they're tendons are as healthy as
those big muscles they're 70 years old
in that movie you're seeing them doing
much sprinting no no let's get this guy
only run free Iran like Anna
40-yard dash yeah they need a
wheelbarrow full of like cadaver tendons
transformers where they turn into
something or two biceps over here
hamstrings and all the muscles pull down
on their ankles
big terrible you know so this is a nerd
thing of body okay so so you get quite
clear that you will fight all of those
guys at once
I'm not afraid at all run away from them
I could the whole time what if they what
if they got ahold of you like sweetie
punch me really slow yeah and then push
it against me they could do it their arm
would rip off just breaks down so all
those elixirs they take in colleges we
talking about elixirs why I know that
they're all-natural that's just a result
of a great diet but might actually be
some narcotics and you're describing
zombies and vampires have you seen the
bolsters yes it looks like the zombie
apocalypse like if you wanted zombies to
be good guys this is your movie Wow 20
seconds well you've challenged them and
then when you do fight them I'm sorry
that's all Randy when you do fight them
I wanted to be here on the show oh yeah
absolutely
I'll do it in a second who do you want
to come first
I won't find Jason Statham he's very fit
Jason or we don't have beer yeah those
guys are Terry Crews okay half the cows
I'd love
but you just want the door for the guys
that that have been around since the 90s
will shatter on impact let's take a
quick break we have not scratched the
surface but we restricted by trying to
keep their wigs on yeah we we've a lien
Aidid good Shrunk the Hollywood let's
take a break I'll never work again yo no
you're done let's talk to our lawyers
more attack Shepherd justice